[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai reçu des dates d'Algérie pour vous
mais j'ai j'avais mal à mon bras de vous
le porter je vais vous les envoyer pour
parler de l'Élysée Président je vous
adore le président un courrier pour vous
oui
accompagné par une escort navale et
aérienne peu avant 8h50 ce matin lotion
Viking entre dans la rade de Toulon à
son bord 230 personnes dont 57 enfants
secouru en Méditerranée au large de la
Libye des migrants immédiatement pris en
charge sur un plan médical et sanitaire
par les autorités trois d'entre eux
ainsi qu'un accompagnant ont déjà été
édittriers hier vers l'hôpital de Bastia
merci Franck merci
merci Billy maintenant on est arrivé à
un point où 70% des Français jugent qui
a trop d'immigrés c'est pas qu'il soit
raciste mais on voit bien que ce qu'il
voudrait c'est au moins gérer le stock
et arrêter le flux vous voyez si tu
aimes la marée basse mon enfant mon
enfant le soleil sous la terrasse sur la
terrasse et la lune sous le vent le
soleil alors il est sûr ou sous la
Terreur
il faut quand même bien dire que vous
balancez sur tout le monde mais vous
aimez les artistes vous aimez les
acteurs vous aimez les comédiens
évidemment qui aime bien châtie bien
c'est pas moi qui l'ai dit c'est Guy
Georges
le film qui est extraordinaire parce que
c'est la conversion au point que tu te
dis mais je vais peut-être me faire
baptiser
sur les plateaux on a une grande crainte
qui revient à chaque sortie de film on
va se dire Michel va spoiler tu es un
spoiler au malentendu au mensonge à nos
silence tous ces moments que j'avais cru
pas [ __ ]
je suis désolé Christophe Licata pour la
finale il a mis fixation effet béton là
je peux vous dire ça ne bouge pas il y a
rien
[Applaudissements]
vous allez
arrêter
en ce moment je sais pas trop pourquoi
je passe du riz au larmes pour rien
manger chaud d'après j'ai froid je suis
totalement à plat je suis fatiguée
je crois connaître le responsable et
comme le chantait Anne Sylvestre c'est
la faute
moi ça m'angoisse reste mon père aille
me voir dans un film comme ça je veux
dire simplement les choses non bien sûr
avec mon père on aime beaucoup échanger
sur les films que je vais faire on en
parle beaucoup là je lui ai dit écoute
papa celui-là on passe et puis c'est pas
grave un film que tu verras pas
les voyait
de famille oui je monte mes gants
la dernière l'armée de l'air américaine
a dû s'expliquer sur ceci regardez c'est
la trajectoire d'un de leurs avions le
dessin format pénis tournait vers une
base militaire oui ici en Syrie les
autorités ont déclaré qu'il s'agissait
d'une simple coïncidence libéré déliv
[Musique]
rée
je n'ai pas
d'oublier ma pile
ou de mettre un stérile
[Musique]
la ménopause est pour moi signe de
liberté
en temps de guerre dans un univers hyper
masculin par excellence il y a une
certaine logique à faire la
démonstration comme ça de son pénis par
contre le faire sur Mars comme la NASA
l'a fait en 2013 avec le robot-over ça
n'a aucun intérêt pour rigoler oui tout
à fait
[Applaudissements]
voilà là c'est typiquement les saisies
que j'aime la circulation est bloquée il
y a des flics de partout il y a un
plateau et il y a des gens qui gueulent
ils s'en souviendront de cette
journée-là pour eux ça fait électrochoc
ça fait des clics ils comprennent que
l'exécution d'une décision du six
passera quel que soit quelle que soit
les moyens mis en oeuvre ça passera
c'est un truc de ouf et en plus on de
ouf en aperçoit ce couple récemment
formé en face Slimane et Bérengère
essayez avec pas mal de succès ce triple
twist
à la pluie c'est la vôtre sera tellement
une note de 6 artistique n'est-ce pas
mon cher Philippe ah ouais ben ça c'est
sûr moi je peux pas faire mieux
est-ce que tu sais ce qui fait ton papa
comme métier
ça veut dire quoi
lui il dit papa tous les matins il va
voler l'argent des gens pour m'acheter
des jouets
il a pas encore bien compris le concept
quoi
vas-y frotte bien dedans cette passion
du ménage elle met un point d'honneur à
la transmettre à ses enfants
il faut que tu appuies et regarde
c'est important qu'elle comprenne des
maintenant que le ménage il faut elle
aussi qu'elle le fasse les enfants
d'aujourd'hui c'est les adultes de
demain